- Creativity matters everywhere,
if you're running for mayor in your town
or if you're running Coca Cola.
(humming boom)
(waves whispering)
- Hi everyone here we are in Cannes,
and I am with the
incredible Gary Vaynerchuk
I am so excited we have
been trying to do this
for the longest longest amount of time,
and he's rocked up today in
a spurs kit which my kids
are absolutely going to love.
Everybody knows everything about you,
you are a serial entrepreneur,
you set up that first business,
a lemonade business age seven.
Now chairman of VaynerX,
the ad agency VaynerMedia
and we're actually going to
talk today about authenticity
and how brands can create real
and meaningful connections
with consumers and I'm
hoping you're gonna share
some of your top tips today.
So welcome to the Facebook
space, thank you for coming.
- Thanks for having me.
- So let's get straight in so tell me,
we're talking about
authenticity in a brand.
What does it mean to you
from a brand communication?
- you know it's, this is
an interesting question,
I have a pretty for this
world a pretty left field
point of view on this, and
my point of view is we need
to achieve relevance I'm
looking at 11, 12, 13 faces
right now and what Pepsi or
BMW or Coca Cola or Facebook
means to all these people
is actually different,
and so for me authenticity
gets very close to relevancy.
Because when you're a big brand
there are so many variables
in your world, there's so many
things that you are doing.
You know some people may
drink a Cola to get a burst
of energy, others it may be
a reminder of spending time
with their grandmother and
I think we're so literal
in today's brand and marketing world.
We're so stuck on
sentences, and adjectives,
and we spend so much
time on subjective things
that don't matter to the
consumer on the other end.
So my perspective is
much like a human being,
you and I are going to
act differently as humans
in this interview than if
we were with our family.
Than if we were on a weekend in Las Vegas
with our best friends,
than if we were presenting
to 5,000 people.
People are always like Gary
you're a little bit different
than when I see you on video,
I'm like yeah I'm on stage
to 7,000 people versus
I'm here with you there's
different versions,
and I think people struggle
in ad land to understand
things that are multidimensional,
and so for me authenticity
is actually being comfortable
in the 74 to 7,400 variations
of how you show up,
and so I think that we are,
that human beings, executives.
Are limiting brands
ability to be authentic
because they want it to be so literal
and so safe and so PR'd and
so approved by the queen bee.
That I think we live in a
very non-authentic world
and I think the reason
humans continue to scale
in popularity is they're a focus group
of the audience, they're
an executive group of one.
And I think one of the
reason real celebrities
are struggling and have lost
share is they do have PR people
they do have big deals with movie studios
that they're scared of breaking,
and so I think anyone
that can actually show
all the versions of themselves will win,
and I think right now
the creative industry
a isn't set up to make enough creative.
B has way to much b to b DNA
in it to actually show up
authentic, and this is not schizophrenia,
this is not throw up against
the wall and see what sticks.
This is not being scattered,
this is being true,
and so I think authenticity
has a far more at its end,
there's always something
that delivers at the end.
A piece of content or creative
and I think it's being far
more wide than it's been
over the last 80 years.
- So who is doing it well,
which brands would you point to,
go nailed it.
- One of the things that
I don't do very well
is pay attention to what
other people are doing.
So this is always a tough question for me.
There is something that's,
you know I thought Wendy's
did a really good job
over the last couple years
of engaging at scale
which then lead to a voice
that gave them a lot of freedom.
But the reality is I know what's going on
in the Vayner world obviously,
I know what's going on
in the broad sense but I
spend almost no time auditing
what other brands are doing,
and plus if we're talking
from a brand standpoint,
well has to be reflected
in business results.
There's a ton of people that
are going to win awards today
that business is declining dramatically
and I struggle with that.
Because the point of that
creativity is to drive
a business result in this context.
Or get people to vote,
or inspire a movement
or cure a disease, what's
the point of output
if you're not getting the end result?
You know I don't know whose doing it well,
I would say whoever's
doing it well is definitely
has business results,
and definitely has a breadth of execution.
- Okay so you've been with businesses
and you've taken businesses from you know,
very small to very big do you
think there's different stages
where authenticity and
creativity matters more?
- No I think it always
matters, as a matter of fact
right now watching everybody pay attention
to all the sound right
behind us, and to me,
and this is not a joke this is very meta.
I have so much empathy especially as DRock
and producers in my world
have come into my world.
The amount of empathy
I have for people that
are incredible at their skill set
and what they think about
is so important to me.
At the same token I genuinely
live in a world where
I think that the person
that's consuming this
on the other side kind
of enjoys the helicopter
or the boat or the
microphone because it's real,
and it's not that my
point of view is right
or production companies points of views
are right or wrong I just think that I'm
fascinated by this notion
and we're living in the
meta of it right now.
First of all to answer
your question directly
because I wanted to
clearly make that point.
Creativity matters everywhere,
if you're running for mayor in your town
or if you're running Coca Cola
and I think if you look
at what's happening.
Look there's a lot of
politicians I desperately
don't agree with but in their authenticity
of being crappy they get an audience,
and I think we have to learn
from that across the board.
- Now earlier this year you
set up another new business,
The Sasha Group all focused
on small businesses,
now what one piece of
advice would you give
to a small business out
there that's looking
to find its voice or its personality?
- That's a great question,
lean into your founder
whether she or he is
introverted or extroverted.
Because they either are extroverted
and charismatic enough
to drive your business
and you're a small company
and you need something.
Or they're introverted
buy they actually know
their craft very well and
thought they may not be
the most dynamic on film
they may be incredible
in podcast form educating
people how to do refrigeration
or how to sell tires
or whatever it may be.
So lean into your founder and
make as much creative output
as you can for the platforms
that are dominating
the mobile device.
The Facebook and Instagrams,
the Snapchats and LinkedIns
the YouTubes of the world is
where the world is now playing,
and making content in written, audio,
or video form for those platforms
is imperative for an SmB.
We were getting tens of
thousands of inquiries
at VaynerMedia from SmBs
and we couldn't take them on
because we're too expensive for them.
Because the business I built
is to service big brands.
But I came from SmB and I almost felt,
almost like a hypocrite slash you know
the reason I named it
directly after my dad Sasha
is 'cause that's my roots
and I thought we were ready
to help that world, and it's been very.
I would tell you honestly,
it's been far more fulfilling
helping these small companies,
I mean there's a nail business in Toronto
that was in deep, deep, deep trouble.
Because their main
distributor was about to,
they thought they might cancel them
and sure enough a year later they did.
But we helped them build a
direct to consumer business
through leaning in to their founder,
I mean I give advice that
actually I watch happen.
We leaned into the founder,
we made a ton of Instagram,
Facebook, Twitter content and
the business is up three x
in revenue, you have to
understand I lived it.
Taking my dad's business
from three mil, four million
to 60 million do you know
how life changing that is
for a business?
I bought my car at a
garage sale for 500 bucks.
My brother got a Lexus
it changes when you build
a business like that,
so you know we're doing
incredible work with Chase and Budweiser
and all this great stuff, but
when you're helping an SmB
and look let's call it what it is.
Being at the Facebook
pavilion, my point of view
from the outside, the small
and medium sized businesses
of the world have figured
out Facebook far far more
than the biggest brands in the world.
Because the biggest brands in
the world deal with audacity
and fake and SmBs can
only live in the truth
because if they live in fake
they go out of business.
- Okay so any favorite
you've mentioned a few,
any favorite platforms or
tools that are really good
for helping these businesses
to build their connections?
Podcast, YouTube, Facebook,
Twitter, Instagram, Snapchat,
LinkedIn has exploded
in the last six months,
LinkedIn acts like Facebook
did six, seven years ago.
Organic reach on LinkedIn is
shocking, so there's that.
Instagram story ads is
the most under priced ad
in the world, buying
Instagram swipe up story ads
that take you exactly to
where we want you to go,
for two to three or four dollars CPMs
and they're actually being seen?
Unheard of so those are some of the things
that I'm excited about.
- Okay and what about your own channels,
your own podcasts--
- I'm dominating, yeah.
It's going great.
- You're own social.
How are you learning to express,
not that I think you have
any troubles with this
but how do you think you're
learning, or tips that
you can give about how you
express yourself personally
and what you're able therefore to transfer
into the brands which
you can communicate for?
- Look the single thing I'm
most proud of sitting at Cannes
is there's not a human here,
not one that makes more
creative output than I do on a daily basis
and collective period,
that is an audacious
but factual statement, there
is not one person here.
That makes more content than I do
and I'm a CEO of a
company, not a creative,
and in that you can
imagine a world where me
and my team are producing 40
to 100 pieces of content a day
across all these platforms,
there's a practitionership
that allows me, I mean
the amount of mistakes
you know it's funny I have DRock here
'cause he's on the text
chain with me and my team.
We change our mind seven times a month,
I constantly shit on my
own self once a week,
I emphatically on Monday
say all about this
and literally next Tuesday
go if we every do that again
we're finished I mean this is real life,
this is the truth--
- you're testing
and learning with yourself.
- At a scale that is unseen right now,
and should be replicated by everyone.
Which gives me much better
insights to what the consumer
is reacting to, and then
obviously I'm a human
with a certain kind of flavor
so that doesn't math to Doug
the same exact way so there's
macro things that we see
that we deploy and then
we see how it plays out,
it's never literal from me to I'm a human,
I'm a 43 year old man
there's a lot of things
that don't navigate.
But there's a lot of truths
that we navigate that we test
and learn there and that we scale,
so it is the ultimate test lab.
- Okay so you, a few
bold statements there.
But I can say you are the
only person in all the years,
and I've interviewed a lot of people.
That has ever walked in
with your own microphone.
'Cause you're literally
just blogging and recording
and observing the whole time.
- And listen when I hear that
sentence my brain goes to
charlatan, self-promoter,
audacious I mean that,
and I'm saying that
because I want the audience
to understand when you're
innovating you're gonna
be misunderstood, when we decided three
and a half years ago to film everything.
I knew that that wasn't gonna
be so easy to navigate life,
I mean this is, at least this
setting is somewhat normal.
How 'bout in your normal
day to day when you're just
going to a normal meeting
and you're being filmed?
People are gonna cast judgment
and I don't want to come across that way.
It's just that the value
of content at scale
is the cost of entry for
success in my opinion
of this next decade and
yeah that's why we do it.
- So you have famously
predicted many trends
that have some true so we couldn't be here
with the helicopters,
planes, boats going on.
What is the next big trend
that you're looking at?
- I think that Alexa and
Google Home is going to be
a major major factor over the next decade
and I implore since were
here, I always think Zucks
has some secret lab when
he's working on this.
'Cause I can't imagine Facebook
not entering this foray,
the attention of the end
consumer's everything.
- You've tried portal.
- Yes I have I have you're right I have,
and to that point that's a solid counter.
I think that voice
activated decision making
is going to be a big deal
because consumers care so little
about privacy and so
much about saving time
and nothing saves you
more time than sitting
in your living room deciding
you want to go to a movie
and it is far faster for
me to say Alexa Portal,
Google Home, whatever Microsoft's got
and whatever some Chinese company's got.
Alexa, what movies are playing?
That is faster than grabbing your phone
and searching Fandango, and in that speed
and getting your answers
will be enormous disruption
over the next decade so
I'm extremely bullish
on voice activated devices.
- Okay we're outta time
you've got a million places
you've gotta go to but we
have our Facebook tradition
of the quick fire round don't
overthink it just say it.
- Do you guys normally play
awesome music right now?
Do you post produce that way?
- You'll post produce that and put it in
and then we want fire and fireworks
and everything in the background,
so first one Cannes or California?
- Cannes, man I really
don't like California.
(laughing)
- I mean you're honest.
- I love California's social
point of view on the world.
- American Football or Baseball.
- American Football.
- Tottenham Hotspur or Tottenham Hotspur?
- Both.
- Okay good answer.
(Gary laughing)
Cardio or weights?
- Cardio.
- Okay.
Podcast or Vlog?
- Oof.
You just literally asked me
what child do I love more?
By the way real quick
on that every parent has
a favorite child.
- That's not true!
- This is absolutely true.
- You're gonna kill me with
my four kids, it's not true.
- It is, four kids
I promise you, you may not wanna know this
but your mom definitely has a favorite.
I'm sure all four of you
actually know who it is.
Like for example in my family
everyone knows it's me.
- Whose interview is this?
(laughing)
- I will go with Podcast,
I like making decisions
I think that audio is passive consumption
and I feel like even a lot
of people who watch my Vlog
actually only watch it with the
audio while they're driving,
working out so I will go
with we are in the rise
of the next decade of audio.
Because we've got faster,
technology's caught up.
We wanna consume information
but having to pay attention
to the video versus listening while
I do something else, not as valuable.
- Okay and just for the record
Gabby, Danny, Sam and Zach.
I love you all equally
don't listen to this man--
- It's Gabby, it's Gabby.
(laughing)
- Final very important
question, Cola or lemonade?
- You know what's interesting,
Cola and this is funny
with a lemon in it.
- That's cheating.
- I only--
- that's cheating--
- No it's not cheating,
what's amazing about
what you asked, actually let
me be even more transparent.
I've stopped drinking Cola as
much over the last five years,
but I've kinda re picked it
up in the last six months
because I've missed it.
I only drink Cola with
lemon and lime in it, only.
I actually dislike, so much
so I don't like regular Cola
anymore, fresh lemon and
lime not when they spice it.
I need to do it, the little pieces
and then I bite the actual
lemon and eat the whole peel
and everyone freaks out.
It's a whole to do.
- These were supposed to be
the don't overthink
it, most people just go
Cola or lemonade, not Gary.
One message that I take
out more than anything,
is experiment, experiment try it.
Don't be afraid be more authentic,
more creative things will happen
and crucially more
business results will come.
Thank you for being with us.
- Thanks for having me.
- I really appreciate it.
(wind rushing)